hey guys Dennis here the founder of
think here I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of the Game of
Thrones Season 4 teaser trailer and the
trailer it just came out right before a
true detective yeah yeah yeah so I mean
you know it's back gotta wait till April
it's almost here beginning of April this
is gonna be the second half basically
the second half of book three I'll be
curious to see how far they go into book
form of course we're not gonna I'm not
gonna spoil anything books you have I'm
not gonna spoil anything but you will
give us maybe some information and you
don't want to hear anything
not spoilers but leave no there's a few
questions that I'll you know I'll ask
you but yeah I love this trailer I've
seen it like five six times already
yeah - yeah you have to watch it yeah
just like all the cool things so like it
opens with the shadow which looks like a
full-grown dragon which of course is
just yeah I mean they they do get bigger
they're not quite that big yet but it's
gonna be I mean I don't know how much
you're gonna agent but in the books in
book three they're not huge huge but I
mean I think it's the more the shaggy no
shadows look big depend on how the Sun
is hitting them but it's an awesome
opening scene I mean the seasons the
trailer for last season season three was
great because it saw the dragon flying
out of the water so again this starts
off again with another great shot of the
Dragons awesome be a specialist of
course they're gonna save probably the
bigger dragons for further expensive
shots looks great I'm sure he brought
you some new curbs I believe from what
I've heard I'm not sure if the mountain
may be recast again I know they are
there's another guy playing the mountain
I don't know if it's the same guys last
seasonings like I had the mountain last
II didn't have a big part I think it was
like one part where he was when Aria was
talking to a Tywin Lannister and he was
at the door or something like he had
come in to tell Tywin something he was
there but not a big compassion the first
season we seen I mean I was in season oh
wow I'm way out what season two let me
know what season two he I think it was
barely and barely in season 3 season 3
yeah barely in it and I think again
they've cast a different guy well he was
a huge Jewish man I liked the first
mountain yeah like tent two and they
changed him after yeah we don't know why
they keep changing the actors around but
I mean whatever yeah we kind of confuse
me because in season two when he did
great show up with the when our
I was talking to with Tywin was like
who's that right and then later it's
like oh that's a bragger Gregorio gained
them out yes so I don't quite like that
who is this one new character in the
trailer that we see that talks about
that the Lannisters are the only not all
the only ones that pay their debts so it
was like a pretty important carrot so
the one group of people that we haven't
seen and I didn't I don't know the
actor's name is the one people that we
haven't seen in a while the the Dorn's I
believe they're called again everyone
gonna get upset like look I've read the
books in like two years so like I don't
wanna read them one time I don't read
them once a year like I don't have a
memorize so I'm sorry but from what I
remember we and they're kind of like I
don't want to generalize but they're
northern African maybe Arab maybe
Persian like a combination of all those
rich they're gonna look more like the
actor does a little bit Middle Eastern
and complexity my skin cut tone and
there they have their own their own
Kingdom in their own not Kingdom but
it's part of the Seven Kings they have
their own area that doesn't get talked
about til later on in the books as much
so this is gonna be a whole new group of
people there's these really hot girls
put in a group like their strong warrior
women you know we're gonna see them
hopefully later they're interesting
group of people that we're still
learning about even in the books that
are currently going on okay so yeah
they're from the south south of the
kingdom
I love the the kind of the soundbite
quotes that they have yeah in this
trailer they have you know first with
with Joffrey of course Joffrey being
Joffrey's like oh they love me I won the
wall I won the war and you know and you
have Jaime Lannister who's now reunited
with this family you might be getting a
hand in the trilogy and put on yeah you
see that he has a fake yeah but you tell
me was like you know the wars not warm
right and of course there's a typical
Joffrey right you know mentality yeah he
thinks everyone loves him he thinks that
everyone thinks he's you know the best
King ever yeah he's done all the stuff
he won he saved this city and saying
what are you talking about you ran
around you ran away like a little [ __ ]
he's a punk man yeah when go fight no it
was actually
Tyrion that was the one who was helping
saving the city but Tyrians in shackles
he's in Chains
yeah yeah so to has his drama going on
of course John
no looking going back up to the north
has escaped the custody of the wild
lanes and now is you can see him it's
not spoil you seem at the trailer
running you know he's going to the wall
yeah to warn them like they're coming
you know because we know that you know
you're disappointed and we need to see a
lot of Hinds
yeah Ciaran Hinds is what's the
king-beyond-the-wall we need to see him
a lot of him but now looks like you know
hopefully we're going to see more of him
this season he's a great act of spoiler
in the in the trailer not that we
thought Jon Snow would die but remember
at the end of last season he's like all
bloody and right you do see him alive
and well well he gets he survives yeah I
better expect him to die like that
I would have shown they was shown
something right he just happened to die
so I mean there's you know the
submerging developments uh you know
what's gonna you know become at the
kingdom they're you know you know
Joffrey what's what's he got going on
you know with his new lady you know some
thoughts it's all over there this is a
lot going on in a Margaery Tyrell
Margaery Tyrell was and then you also
have Danny who not as bad as Joffrey not
even close but she does have a mentality
of entitlement like this is mine this is
right this is gonna be a new world and
they can either live in it or they're
gonna die and and you have warm on
alright yeah mmm telling her like and
it's very what I love about Game of
Thrones it's it's not black and white
it's all grey he's saying like in every
war there's good people and bad people
on both sides cuz even the books Danny
always bothered me because I always
appreciate her strength and I appreciate
where she comes when she's always so
like black and white with like she has
the right to rule and I'm like but what
makes you better than anybody else like
she has this whole thing like oh the
kingdom people are gonna want to come to
me I'm like maybe not you know you're
kind of crazy you know in a little bit
she's ruthless I'm she's strong but
she's ruthless she's we saw at the end
of last season she's starting to kind of
have this Jesus yeah people carrying her
lifting her up in like worshiping her
and all this so yeah I mean Danny's
there's a lot going I mean you got you
got Sam you got poor Sam you know I'm
talking about Sam there's we saw a quick
shot of Aria like Aria looks like she's
training I mean she's always beating
interested in he's on the road we don't
know where she's gonna end up she's in
Road right now with what's-his-name with
the hound the hound yeah so I mean it's
there's just so much good stuff coming
up in this season this is the second
half book 3 is my favorite book threes
my favorite this is the second half of
that book there's still more drama to
come those boys they're still great
stuff to come and of course the end with
a great line with with Tyrion about like
if you if you've come here for justice
you've come to the wrong place which is
basically talk about Game of Thrones
like if you're watching Game of Thrones
and the good guys to win and for yeah
like it's not gonna Starks to come back
yeah like this is not the show for you
yeah no this is just always going
downhill yeah if you like you know puppy
dogs and rainbows right yeah good guy
always winning this Watson once upon a
time it's a good show I like that show
yeah watch a different show cuz I show
is I think ultimately just it's every
every season they just break your heart
ya know something about you like this
this character Oh we'll kill them let's
not forget about Lady Brienne Tarth
she's still you know I see what happens
there's a lotta good stories coming up
in this season I can't wait to talk
about it alright guys so that's what we
don't have the teaser trailer let us
know what you thought you can post your
comments below on the website thank you
or calm or on our YouTube channel think
your all-pro make sure you subscribe to
that also come check us out on Twitter
chat with us let us know about Game of
Thrones we find us at think hero I'm
personally at Griffin de we also have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans make sure you like that
page and share our videos on Twitter or
Facebook and wherever Thanks